Good morning, Hank, It's Tuesday.
So this is a video about mental illness
I think I'm gonna do it in the format, actually
So I've had a rough couple months
My OCD and anxiety have been really high
and I've also had this lengthy bout of depression
It started about nine weeks ago
amid really good news, actually
Our community had this huge win
We helped encourage this company, Danaher,
to lower the price of its tuberculosis tests
which is going to allow 5 million more
people to be tested for TB every year
It's incredible
But when that news happened, I just,
I felt nothing but dread
It was just this, like, terrible, indescribable fear
In fact, the indescribability is
part of the problem, right?
Because that's part of what makes
it so difficult to share
or to feel unalone in
I can really only approach it
through metaphor or simile
It felt like a...
blanket of dread just descended
Honestly, I don't know what else there is
to say about it. It just kind of sucks.
When I was in my 20s, there was some
naive part of me that thought
if I could just make it to middle age,
all of this would be behind me
And that hasn't turned out to be the case
But what is the case is that
even when I can't feel it,
I understand intellectually that this is temporary
and that this isn't telling the full story of
what it means to be a person in the world
And I know that if I just keep pursuing treatment, work with my doctor, take my medicine, move my body when I can, all that stuff,
eventually I will feel different
I do think I might be starting to get better.
It's been a little better in the last week.
That's why I'm able to make a video at all.
But there have been a lot of false dawns,
and you never know.
Speaking of which, let's get a check on the dawn.
So it's like too gray and rainy for there to
even  be a visible dawn
which you know, as a metaphor is a
little bit on the nose.
Susan Sontag described depression as
melancholy minus its charms
which I like a lot because
first it acknowledges the charms of melancholy
Like when you're driving alone at night,
there's something sad about it, but
there's also something beautiful and lovely about it
Like when I feel melancholic, there's something
beautiful and rich and productive about it.
Whereas when I feel depressed, everything is stolen away
except for the sadness and the weight on my chest
I worry this video is going to suck
because, like, the thing that it's about sucks
It's just like a piano that's off key,
playing one note over and over
despair, despair, despair
But I have to reject the idea that
that tells the whole story,
because it just doesn't
A young woman I knew a little,
Casey McIntyre, just died of cancer.
She was married to my friend
Andrew Rose Gregory of the Gregory brothers,
and she also worked for many years at the same
publishing house where I published my books.
Anyway, in lieu of, like, flowers
at a memorial service or whatever
what she really wanted to do was
erase people's medical debts
One of the many insanities of the
US Healthcare system is that
so many people are bankrupted
just for being sick
And so Casey wanted to have this, like,  debt jubilee
And incredibly, people have raised enough money
to cancel $50 million of medical debt
over the last few days in Casey's memory
I'll put a link in the doobly do if you want to join us in donating
But what a lovely way to remember someone
and to take care of each other.
To be honest with you, sometimes
I just hate the world
The hopelessness feels so complete
But then think of all these people coming together to cancel
$50 million in medical debt in memory of a lovely person.
To me, that's the complex story of being a person
We cannot save those we love from suffering
as much as we desperately want to
We cannot make life fair or just
But we can reach out to each other,
help each other, cancel each other's debts
We can be careful of each other
As Philip Larkin put it:
we can be kind while there is still time
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.